awesome all right uh welcome to the ddps
seminar everyone before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all please meet
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions if you
have a questions you are welcome to mute
and ask otherwise please use chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in Q a session at the end
second today's gdps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed
please watch out finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host the Spencer uh Prince uh
bringelson who is an assistant professor
in the College of computing at Georgia
Tech previously he was a senior
postdoctoral researcher at Caltech with
Team Colonius a visiting the researcher
at MIT with tami's sepsis and a
postdoctoral researcher at the center
for extra scale simulation of plasma
coupled combustion with Carlos Pantano
and Dan bodony he received his PhD and
Ms in theoretical and applied mechanics
from the University of Illinois at
Urbana Champaign in 2017 and 2015.
[Music]
uh working with the Jonathan Floyd
in 2013 he received Bachelor's in
science degree in both mechanical
engineering and Mathematics from the
University of Michigan Dearborn
Spencer won a few hours like the young
investigator award from Oak Ridge
National Lab the UIUC outstanding
dissertation award and the UIUC hasn't
arrived over the full research and fluid
dynamics today Spencer will talk about
comparative physics informed
networks which is a very interesting
topic please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk now without the further
due let me test the button to Spencer by
asking one random question really really
random questions
uh the random question is what is the
most
irrational superstitions you have if you
have one most irrational superstition
that I have I'm not a very superstitious
person yes
um
I guess maybe most scientists aren't uh
I don't know how to answer that question
uh let me ask another question okay uh
you got it uh I have a superstitious
that Consciousness is not real uh how
about that
oh okay it's a weird that's that's a
weird it's a weird weird answer but uh I
think it's uh it may be a somewhat
controversial one so uh I think it makes
sense yeah it's a perfect answer well
the we are the question okay uh if the
Stacy is yours
thank you young Sam uh okay uh well
thanks everyone for having me uh that's
it and thanks for the uh nice
introduction uh so physics informed
neural networks are a Hot Topic as uh
yongsu has alluded to
um and so we're gonna get down to some
nitty-gritty details here about what I
think is going on in this research area
and
um maybe some of the problems that exist
and some potential solutions to them
um which I understand is a bit vague but
uh we'll get there
um all right first uh we'll do the
acknowledgments at the beginning so I
don't forget uh so really the brains
behind this operation are two
outstanding students uh SI Zhang and
Joshua Authority uh they are two great
students that work in my research group
I also have an outstanding collaborator
uh Professor Florence Schaefer uh who is
also in uh the same Department as I am
and is sitting a couple of offices away
from me right now
um so I'm very uh grateful for them and
they uh contributed to this work as well
um and there's a paper that is
associated with much of this work that
you can refer to as as you see fit
um it's on the archive and it was just
accepted to iClear uh 2023.
okay uh so let's first do just a quick
overview of what type of physics and
form neural network is um even though
maybe many people know but we'll do a
quick introduction
um so the idea of a physics form neural
network is simply that
um number one uh your task is that you
want to solve a pde and uh the way
you're going to do it is you're going to
encode the solution to that pde into a
neural network the neural network
doesn't necessarily have a very
complicated topology it's in many cases
just a multi-layer perceptron though
some people have experimented with
different types of architectures but at
the end of the day it's just a neural
network in which you are encoding the
solution to a pde via training
um and and that's it
um and then so in the way that this is
done is that the loss function for the
training of this pde is simply the mean
squared error so the a difference
between the exact solution to the pde
and and the one that you observe so this
is but and so the magic of this or the
seaming magic of this is that through
back propagation you can get the all of
these that you can accumulate the
derivatives to any partial differential
equation you may have on hand or
ordinary differential equation
um such that you don't actually need to
really have any data on hand all you
really need to have is the pde and then
I can then formulate what Solutions are
I can create a neural net I train a
neural network to represent its solution
which is a really um uh clever little
trick
um that uh sort of bypasses problems of
oh well how do I come up with so-called
you know truth data and so on and so
forth and because of its Simplicity this
is why uh it's it's it's so uh popular
seemingly these days
but no I I thought um I'd be remiss
without doing a little bit of uh of
archeology here
um so the idea of introducing
um physic physical constraints in this
case a partial differential equation
um but of course one can imagine other
physical constraints
um being integrated into a artificial
neural network is actually a rather old
idea or at least rather old by uh by
neural network standards artificial
neural network standards and the
research in the field so if we actually
go back to 1994 Thompson and Kramer they
introduced these ideas of intermediate
variables and residual modeling as a way
of actually solving uh for for models
and now they weren't necessarily solving
pdes that may have been beyond their
computational capabilities at the time
but they had this very similar
fundamental idea
um and so and so that was uh quite
interesting and it didn't really gain a
tremendous traction at the time but they
had seemingly the core idea there that
that seems to come ever so naturally to
us once once you're told it at the very
least
um there's also this idea of
physics-based pre-processing where you
um inject some prior physical knowledge
and then and then you train your neural
network model
um so you do this sort of ahead of time
instead of during training
um and so that that also has been around
for a long time uh at least since 1998
if not earlier
um and so humans that we have this idea
that if our neural network isn't really
doing what we want um maybe what we can
do is we can just inject some Physics in
some sense or some sort of mathematical
representation of that physics and that
will make things better
and so uh it turns out that that idea is
not uh extremely new
uh and we can go on and on in 2005 uh uh
folks came up with the idea of a finite
element neural network where all of the
weights that compose the neural network
were actually pre-computed because
people had an idea of what they should
be to begin with because people under
have understood finite element methods
for a long time so people tried that as
well and had some success
um and then we go further and further
and there's some work in 2007 where
people are incorporating physical models
as neural network constraints and had
more and more success as as more
computational resources were available
so here we're looking at something like
a constitutive law on the top in order
to get some temperature of a material
um so none of these specific
applications for ideas notwithstanding
the reason that perhaps
um they uh didn't get a ton of traction
is because uh maybe we just weren't
quite ready for them
um and or we didn't both in terms of
sort of computational horsepower or in
terms of uh the software tooling needed
in order to make them easy to create
um but it just so happens around uh
maybe the mid 2010s that these types of
tools became uh common
um so I'm thinking of things like pie
torch and tensorflow and so on as well
as gpus started exploding onto the scene
where now sort of everyone can have
access to a GPU or a small cluster of
gpus in order to train these things and
between the two it sort of was just the
right sort of mixture of things in order
to pop out these things deemed physics
informed neural networks which is a
quite similar idea but it was just
really came in at the right time and um
and uh and showed all sorts of uh great
examples about what these things can do
and uh so this is of course the the
quite now uh famous paper of veracity
prayer decaris and George carnidakis
that I think many of us are familiar
with
so pins pop into the scene in 2019
though the archive version of their
paper was I believe 2017.
um and so since then we've had a bit of
a research explosion in this area
basically all of these papers in this
review so you can find this on the
archive and this is a separate paper
um our our uh are are purporting to to
try to sort of hammer away at um at
we're attempting to to hammer away at
this problem and in in in all sorts of
from from basically every different
angle
um and I think we're we're going to get
to in this talk we're going to get to
the point of why so many of these papers
exist why we're looking at uh there's
references here at least on this slide
into the 300s
um so part of this is because uh that
this tool is powerful but part of it is
because it actually needs some help
um so I'm going to get to that uh next
okay so uh so this is to to bring us
back uh after this uh uh short uh
history lesson
um this is again what a physics informed
neural network looks like and um and uh
I'll recall to you that uh this MSC here
stands for mean squared error so this is
like an L2 error on basically the
difference between the solution
um or the residual of a pde so maybe you
want to focus on this part where my
pointer is this F minus LaPlace U so
here we're just solving a poisson-like
equation so this is the pde residual and
then this other term is just uh sitting
in for the boundary conditions perhaps
it's not especially important
um but here this thing in the loss
function which is really the main meat
of what makes up a neural network and
it's certainly how it is trained is
is what's going on here and so uh I I
suggest and I I hope to show some
evidence that
um this is actually part of the Crux of
of what will become a problem
okay so the problem here is that
um these physics-informed neural
networks if I give them a pde if I give
them the new base Stokes equations if
they give if I give it even seemingly
sometimes quite benign pdes or even Odes
then it will struggle to come up with a
accurate representation for the solution
it will the lot and what I mean by that
is essentially that the loss function
will actually not decrease
um uh to a very low level so here we're
thinking about something on the order of
like one percent L2 error
um and of course it can be much worse
than this there are some cases where
some pdes just do not train at all so
you start off with some error and then
nothing basically nothing happens as you
go through training and this is well
documented I put some example papers
here there's probably been even more
since since I first created this slide
like a couple months ago so
um so uh this is this is well documented
and the question is well what's going on
here why can't I train my neural network
my PIN to represent this pde wouldn't it
be so great if I could and it turns out
that and it's not really clear what the
reason is because it's sometimes sort of
butts its head in uh into
um
it butts its head into seemingly benign
pdes whereas for a more complicated
looking pde everything is just fine and
if you get also in the training error is
quite low and everyone's happy
um so the the question is what what is
going on here
so how do we fix this thing and I hope
to to talk about that next
okay so
um my suspicion here uh which I hope to
convince you of is that uh the main
cause of this problem is that these
problems are poorly conditioned so the
pin loss function is this L2 like error
or this squared error involving
differential operators of course they
can be of higher differential order
which would only make the problem worse
um and so but then at the end of the day
the problem we're actually trying to
solve so if we just think about this in
the context of a discretized linear
problem and discretize linear
differential operator so something again
seemingly benign in this case a poisson
equation
um then uh then this is the problem that
you're trying to solve here right and so
we know that this is the solution to
this minimization problem and if you put
this thing through gradient descent this
is going to be essentially what gets
computed and and the problem that that
tries to get solved now and and you're
solving here for you that's the solution
field that you want and you can have the
once you actually have that thing you
can evaluate it anywhere in say space or
if this was the time dependent you could
evaluate it in time
um and so on and so forth
um but uh but if if we remember our uh
numerical linear algebra we see that
there's something quite uh nasty about
this this this problem
um which is that this a transpose a
inverse is actually a quite nasty thing
this is akin to solving the normal
equations for a linear system
um which squares the condition number of
that operator so if a is encoding any
differential information this is we are
now squaring that condition number which
is something that we all learned that we
we don't want to do
um sometime when during our schooling uh
and so this is essentially what's
happening every step through uh
evaluating the loss and doing your
gradient descent or however you would
like to optimize your uh your neural
network your your PIN
okay so this uh seems to be a key uh a
problem to what's going on
um and so uh instead a way to fix this
um partially is to get rid of this L2
type business
um but the problem is that you don't
really want to give up this L2 type
property because it has this nice
convexity properties and and L2 is nice
for all sorts of other reasons so you
don't really want to leave the L2 space
um and instead you'd like to solve this
in perhaps a different way and so this
is where
um uh where I think a reformulation of
it of otherwise the same problem uh is
beneficial and so here we are recasting
the same problem as instead a Mini Max
minimization problem so the a Mini Max
uh prop solution to the same problem so
here we um are minimizing now the
solution to this pde where here Pi steps
in as the solution uh so this is still
the pde residual in the parentheses and
then B serves as something that looks
like a discriminator that is imposing
penalties onto this thing and so this is
a so-called Mini Max problem where the D
is trying to penalize solutions that are
um uh porcelain uh is trying to is
trying to penalize mistakes that are
made by the approximation pi and vice
versa Pi is trying to minimize the term
that are in parentheses such that this
is this is small and so this is a back
and forth game that is going on between
these two agents
um and so if you recast this Minimax
game into its linear formulation which
is is what's shown here
um then it turns out that the condition
number of this linear system has the
same condition number as original
derivative operator and so things are uh
are better posed
um and so that can uh save quite a bit
of of heartache and I'll I hope to show
you some examples about why why uh that
that are compelling that suggests that
this is important
okay
um so the next question is that uh that
we need to implement this thing
um so we have here this Mini Max game in
the top left here's our pde residual for
our sort of toy pde the or uh our
poisson problem and we have our
discriminator hanging out here and this
is what the architecture looks like so
now we have two multi-layer perceptrons
in this case
um one serves as the neural network
representing the discriminator and the
other serves as what we uh what is our
our good friend the pin that is going to
give us the solution uh in this case Pi
but otherwise they're up to
um the same business except that they
are now competing but now we see that
the loss function looks a little bit
different we have products here for
example between D the discriminator and
the the residual between the
um uh the residual of the pde that we
hope to solve so we see that this no
longer looks like an L2 type mean
squared loss function this looks
different
um
so that's what the architecture looks
like and now the the next question is
how does one actually go about
optimizing such a a type of game between
this discriminator and this pin Network
um and so that's where this idea of
competitive optimization comes in so it
turns out that this is a quite necessary
task and I'll make the argument for that
in a moment
um but what one can imagine in the C pin
instance that's what we call it these
competitive pins is that the
discriminator is acting as one agent
that is trying to do what's in its best
interest which is to penalize the
mistakes of mismatching mismatching the
solution to the pde and the Y is the
actual PD residual which is trying to be
as small as possible so these this X and
Y these two agents X and Y are in
competition with each other
okay and so one can think about this as
sort of like a cat and a mouse where the
mouse is this Agent X and the Y is the
is the cat
um and uh and they're each hoping to
minimize their respective loss functions
f and g because the cat wants to get The
Mouse and the mouse does not want to be
gotten by the cat uh so both so um so
the thing to notice here is that the
loss of each of these the F's and the
G's depends on what the other one does
and so it turns out that this is rather
important so what they the cat or what
the mouse does influences what the cat
should do next and vice versa so um and
this can go back and forth actually if
you think about this in sort of finite
time steps Um this can go back and forth
sort of infinitely many times like what
would I do if what would if if he knew
what I was going to do and back and
forth and back and forth and back and
forth until you reach an equilibrium
okay but we're going to get to that a
little bit more uh in a moment
um but uh but I'd like to get into just
a little bit more detail here because I
think it's helpful
um so one one thing to notice here is
that these two agents they have
conflicting goals so what what is good
for the mouse is bad for the cat and
vice versa which is uh shown here as uh
the they are basically in essence uh
opposite uh types of loss functions
which again are akin to our sequence
instance
and um and so one way of viewing this is
okay well why can't I just do my regular
gradient descent type of algorithms or
something like them in order to solve
this problem so let's look at what
regular gradient uh descent or what I
like to call simultaneous gradient
descent looks like for for such a
problem with two agents so here we have
the update on X and uh on the left and
the update on y on the right and so what
you see is that the um what what the X
will do only depends on what what the Y
did at the previous step so the next the
basically the update only depends on why
at the previous step and vice versa y
only depends on what x did at the
previous step
okay and so we can see that if one
actually goes through with this strategy
that is in these that's embodied in
these two little equations that this
strategy actually diverges even on uh
quite simple examples so if the loss
function of F the agent f is just this
inner product between X and Y which
happens to be at odds with the loss
function of G so let's just Define this
so there's like a triple equality here
um as minus G because they want to do
opposite things they have opposite
objectives then
um this this thing even diverges here
and so that's what's shown in the
picture where here basically the the
state of the agent X and the agent Y is
plotted on this two-dimensional axis so
that makes up one Circle here and then
the arrow represents the direction that
the basically
um the the loss functions are pointing
you in
but we see that this this basically
diverges in this spiral-like fashion and
the reason for that is because for
example if agent F were to play in a in
for example in this in rock paper
scissors if the agent
um uh F were to play Rock then the agent
y word r would know then next to pick
paper and then after agent F observes
that agent y or or Jeep pick paper it
would then pick scissor and back and
forth and back and forth and back and
forth and Not only would you not
converge but you would actually diverge
in this sort of spiral like fashion so
this type of typical gradient descent
does not work on these types of of game
formulations that I've laid out in the
previous slides
okay so then the question is how does
one uh linearize a game such that we can
get some type of uh gradient descent
descent like algorithm because we know
they are useful uh in order to carry out
uh this optimization in a way that
doesn't have these nasty properties and
perhaps one that's even kind of good
um so one idea is to just have uh one
agent so and where the optimal strategy
is just the regularized linear local
approximation of what it should be doing
and the other is to have two agents
where the optimal strategies are
linearized local approximations for both
of the agents
um but then the the question remains how
do you actually linearize in order to uh
to deal with these problems and so I'm
going to briefly go through the math of
of how these terms show up and hopefully
that uh makes things uh a bit more uh
interactive here and more interesting
and so here let's look at um what what
is basically essentially uh
straightforward gradient descent
um on the uh the update to Agent X and
the update to agent y on the top and
bottom respectively
um and so uh here well what we see is
that if this is linear for one agent
then it is actually linear for two
agents so this is just the gradient what
you're looking at at the top is just the
gradient descent update for um so how X
should change and uh here this is just
sort of the the truncated Taylor series
um so you have the argman of the
objective function f
um and then you have your your gradient
terms and X and Y that show up evaluated
of course at x sub k y sub K and then
you have this regularization term that
basically
um uh enforces or penalizes good or bad
behavior which looks like this inner
product term so this this sort of
corresponds to how big of a step you
would take given the the confidence that
you have in your in your objective
function and the same thing is on the
bottom except now we're looking at G's
instead of F's and we're looking at y's
instead of x's but otherwise things are
the same and we still end up with these
two terms showing up here except again
with with the G
okay and so I think the the interesting
part that will that will come up here is
that if you do this with sort of normal
gradient descent uh then uh and you and
you linearize this problem what you will
find is that all of these cross terms
the terms that perspective that that
potentially could give the information
about what the the cat should do knowing
what the mouse would do and what the
mouse should do knowing what the cat
should do
um are actually banished because this
term does not depend on Y and then this
term is evaluated such that uh is not
evaluated at any uh this derivative
vanishes because it's constant with
respect to X
um and and vice versa here so this term
ends up being a constant it goes away
this derivative with respect to X goes
away and so the only terms that you hold
on to are the normalization terms of
course and then these highlighted terms
that are basically what we already went
through they're the terms that say okay
well well I'm the cat so I know that I
should be doing such and such
um but it's not taking in this this
intrinsic missing information about
um what the cat would do knowing what
the what the mouse would do and vice
versa there's no sort of cross terms
that exist here so this actually just
turns into and the same goes for the
mouse on the bottom
um and so this just turns into
simultaneous gradient descent once again
but then the interesting part is that
there's there's no reason there's
there's actually additional terms that
could be kept that are linear here so
the additional terms are these cross
derivatives
um and in this case D X Y of the the
second derivative operator that are
shown in the middle here and these
represent what the cat would do knowing
what the mouse would do and vice versa
and they show up in both the bot the top
and the bottom terms one thing to notice
here is that even though this represents
a a Hessian it only represents the off
diagonal terms so
um and so the there's um this is still
linear it is not uh non-linear and it
doesn't result in any uh other nasty um
uh second order derivatives
okay and so this this allows them
basically both to peek at each other and
go back and forth
um uh back and forth in order to uh to
to make basically the best update and
now
um and so this is uh an interactive type
of procedure
um now there's only one step left in
this in this business which is
um to find the Nash equilibrium which is
that if I know that you know that I know
that you know about the steps that I'm
going to make next then you can iterate
this over and over and over again to
find the Nash equilibrium where it no
longer makes sense for me to move in a
certain direction because knowing what
you would do next I would do nothing
different and vice versa
um so uh in this case both players are
satisfied with their positions and then
you make an update and so it turns out
that you can just get this from a
truncated Lu decomposition and taking
that to an infinite power and then you
get the Nash equilibrium and so this
thing serves as the new update rule that
makes up the basis of cgd or competitive
gradient descent so this is just the
thing that that serves as our new update
Rule and we argue that this is a natural
generalization of gradient descent to
multiple agents without bearing uh undue
computational costs or anything nasty
like that
okay so that's how we actually go about
our
um our optimization procedure and that
uh it turns out that the Nash
equilibrium of this game actually is the
exact solution to the pde so um so
there's actually no conflict there that
that's actually a a nice uh mathematical
fact that can be proved
okay so how does this thing perform I I
purport that uh this is uh such a such a
nice idea or something that uh I guess I
should show some evidence that it has
some some nice features
um so here what we do is um the number
of forward we count the number of
forward passes instead of the number of
epochs because in the C pins procedure
one has to account for this Hessian
Vector product this which is associated
with these cross terms that I mentioned
that that make cgd what it is instead of
just simultaneous creative descent so
instead in order to fairly uh take uh
take into account the computational cost
we count the number of forward passes as
opposed to the number of epochs
um and then we plot that against the L2
relative error which is nominally what
you actually care about
um and we see that
um even on a 2d poisson problem a nice
uh smooth one nothing particularly nasty
about it over about uh one two three
like four there's a magnitude the PIN
instance had the traditional pin trained
with a regular gradient descent here
with Adam basically with its special
update rule has decreased by less than
an order of magnitude over all of those
forward passes in terms of L2 relative
error whereas the C pin is able to get
down to single Precision error so this
is carried out on a single Precision
Hardware so this is actually as good as
we can hope to do and it does it in an
efficient way as well so so it works
here nicely
um and then the other
um uh argument that one uh may be
thinking about making is is is along the
lines of
um well what about uh you're you're
saying you're using Adam
um well maybe I should just be using
some orders of other special
um Optimizer and that will take care of
the problem
um and we we actually did an ablation
study uh on a whole slew of different
algorithms both the most popular ones
and other ones that people more modern
ones that people uh argue for and we
found that this red curve which is the
one that I presented before
um called a cgd
um which uh where the a is in a
particularly important but the point is
that it outperforms
um in a quite meaningful way all of
these other uh other things other
optimizers
um
which is great uh and I also mentioned
the difference between forward passes
and uh epochs or iterations uh so you
see if we actually just take into
account iterations then uh then our
method here in red looks even better but
I think that's a bit of an unfair way of
thinking about it but I put it there
just for reference
okay I have one more slide
I think
um and it's on the base Stokes so
there's been all sorts of efforts on
trying to train Nevada Stokes and all
sorts of papers just about training pins
on Nivea Stokes and so we thought we
would give it a go
um and so uh my argument here is that
over all of these orders of magnitude of
forward passes basically the pin is not
training at all so this is being trained
on a uh to solve a steady uh cavity flow
problem a lid driven cavity flow problem
and um it it decreases in relative error
by like a factor of of like two over all
of these forward iterations the the
physics informed neural network with
Adam and to be clear again I'm only
showing the best results for the physics
and form neural networks with for the
various optimizers I'm not showing the
ones that do worse
um and but for the C pin we do get
convergence it's a bit noisy which I
have some ideas about why that may be
but
um uh suffice it to say that it does
seem to be converging all be it quite uh
slowly so this requires a bit more
attention about what could be going on
here but it has some similar
characteristics
okay so uh so that's basically the end
of of my talk and I hope I left enough
time for uh questions
um the key takeaways here is that
there's a training problem that is
associated with this um this squared
loss function and that remedying the
squared loss function is not maybe as
trivial as it seems and it involves sort
of actually changing the architecture of
how one goes about solving this problem
and using sort of a little bit more
specialized uh optimization methods
there are a bunch of good results that
we have for other equations that I
wouldn't burden you with showing you
solutions for the burgers equation
Schrodinger Allen con equation and so on
and so forth so we do quite well for
those as well
um and uh and the new gay Stokes also
does well but uh needs a bit more
attention that we're looking into so the
code for this is openly available under
MIT license you're welcome to to have it
and play around with it if you if you
see fit
um so I'd like to thank you for your
time and for the invitation I hope this
was uh in any way interesting
um and I am of course happy to take uh
your questions
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk Spencer very informative
and
um easy to follow
um
in my opinion and also there were like
tons of discussions in the chapter
follow every single things but um let's
let's do this in Q a session
um let's give a you know the chance to
ask questions in you know in verbally
um hopefully their Sound Works let's
start with a Mark Miller
um if you're okay to mute yourself and
ask your question directly that would be
wonderful sure maybe I'll just ask the
last one great talk I I wasn't able to
follow all of it but I I really enjoyed
it uh so I had a silly question here
towards the end what do you have a sense
of maybe what the total flop count is
for Solutions via cpin versus
traditional numerical Solutions the same
quality
yeah good question so we try to take
that um into account with our our
business of forward passes versus
iterations here
um so actually what's going into this
forward pass computation is we actually
we aren't taking into account
um per se the exact Lop count because
that uh could could become a bit more
complicated one thinks about that people
are doing you would you would normally
do this on gpus so I I'm not sure that
that flop count per se is the the
perfect metric but um but instead what
we do is we just take into account the
nominal number of of sort of operations
that are required in order to do the the
Hessian Vector product which is the main
thing that actually changes the the cost
between the regular pin and the C pin so
that's the main difference and that is
the thing that we add to the cost which
gives this difference between the plot
on the left and the plot on the right in
terms of Shifting the spread curve to
the right
um as well as the yellow curve that's
somewhat less less important
okay Mark Marcus you know talking about
the traditional numerical methods like
the final element finite Difference by
the way oh are you talking if oh sorry
if you're yeah yeah yeah thank you sorry
I totally misunderstood no problem no
problem it's when I it's one I totally
get all the time so I can so yeah yeah
yeah so you're yeah the question then is
um if I understand correctly is
um well what if I want to just solve the
same problem using a finite element
method um to solve the pde in the same
way
um so I uh I totally sympathize with
everyone that wants to do this and I
actually suggest you do do it um if you
uh have a traditional solver to solve
via finite elements or something your 2D
person equation and you're happy with
that it will actually be much faster to
deal with that than to deal with
training a pin and solving it that way
not only will you get smaller errors in
your traditional solver but you will um
solve it faster now the the and what I
what I sort of hit here and maybe I
should have shouldn't have is that
um the real value value in these pins
things in in my view and maybe other
people have other views but the main
value is that these things are useful
for many query problems many query
meaning that I can train this pin to
also be uh be parametric so you know you
can imagine the flow over an airfoil and
then I train this pin on a whole bunch a
whole bunch of pdes where the where the
parameter is say the angle of attack and
now I can probe that thing as basically
for free because the thing is
represented as this small compact nice
little neural network but if you want to
solve a million uh finite elements
solve the final element equations a
million times for different angles of
attack then then I would argue that
that's that's not really a very fruitful
way to go and the the more promising
area here is these many query problems
super thanks so much really enjoyed it
thank you
uh let's go to Majid Majid um
for you uh hello can you hear me yep
yeah yeah
um so I didn't actually write any
questions in the chat uh but I can ask
you a question if if that's okay yeah go
ahead go ahead yeah thanks for a great
talk actually I mean I there's a study
it feels a little bit different from
many other applications so it's nice to
get to the root of the problem with pins
um my question is uh so uh the problems
that you showed here like the 2D
problems
um I'm just wondering do you think
finding the best Optimizer will solve
all the problems with pins or using
neural networks to solve pdes
um for instance for let's say problems
that they have time component or 3D or
where they have high frequencies and
things like that
um yeah I guess my question is like what
so
um I see there can be one problem with
optimization right and they can be one
problem with neural network not being
expressive enough to solve every kind of
pdes that we deal with so just wanted
wondering about your comments you know
like your thoughts on that
okay yes thank you for your question I
think I understand it so
um the so there's a couple things first
uh number one I I should say I don't
purport uh uh and I hope I didn't give
the impression that I I that we're
somehow solving every pin problem that
that exists
um uh just maybe a couple of the ones
that people have been
um noticing uh often
um and that seemed to be uh uh uh
important to getting to the bottom of
some of these other things
um so that's that's the deal with this
this conditioning that can be solved via
a Mini max type of of architecture and
then uh competitive Optimizer
um so that can be what's solved there
now um regarding your sort of other
questions
um whether one is
um
whether whether one is thinking about
higher dimensional problems so the part
of the reason I actually didn't solve
show higher dimensional problems is that
higher dimensional problems are actually
easier for a a pin like uh thing or
really any type of neural network uh uh
type architecture because they don't
suffer from the cursive dimensionality
in the same way that a traditional
solver would so if you had for example
and and a lot of people do this and
perhaps it's a bit unfair
um for them to do so but point is that
as you go to higher and higher
Dimensions so if I think of like the 10d
poisson problem all of a sudden a neural
network type solution for that problem
actually looks very very competitive
compared to any type of traditional
solution to that problem because as the
the expressivity of the neural network
remains intact but the uh expressivity
or the the amount of operations that one
would have to do to solve this in a in a
sort of normal numerical methods way
does not and it scales um to the power
of that Dimension so that's a nasty
problem and uh and and actually that's
another place maybe if I were to add
another bullet point uh down here to
this slide it would be also useful for
many dimensional problems um and so if
those are interests of you to you then
uh things like these types of neural
network expressivities things are are
quite attractive
um the other uh point you made uh was
just regarding expressivity in terms of
what if my
um my solution to my pde has let's say
some really nasty features some highly
oscillatory features or something like
that does the neural network have enough
expressivity in order to accommodate for
those kinds of solutions at least if
that if I'm understanding the point
correctly exactly and and I think so
there's a couple of things one is that
this um there's this idea of uh that the
neural networks serve as universal
approximators so and so which I think in
many cases is used as a bit of a red
herring but the point is that uh but but
the point is still true is that um the
price efficiently deep and wide neural
network any type of solution can be
expressed
um so so that's that is true and now now
what in more practical terms if if one
had a really nasty equation and would
would
um how how big would the neural network
have to be and would it be worth making
a neural network that large in order to
get that kind of expressivity
um is a question that I'm not really
prepared to answer but it would
um but at in some limit it would be able
to do so
interest thank you thank you for your
comments great talk thank you
okay thank you uh let's move on to
repang I know he just commented on it
but um let's give him a chance oh okay
thanks thank you thank you if I can ask
uh some questions this is a very great
talk I'm very interested in this topic I
think my first question is uh actually
on on that's on the slide you you are
showing here I think at the very
beginning of your talk you said some
good features of of pin because you
don't need the uh much data and you have
some information in the back propagation
I think I didn't hear that very well can
you can you please uh comment on that
again
uh absolutely yeah so this comes down to
the Crux of what a pin actually is
um which is the idea that I'm what I
want to do is I want to solve a pde so
what I'm showing here is a a toy pedia a
poisson problem so I have the laplacian
of U equals f
um and so I'm just basically sticking
this thing into the loss function or the
error the mismatch the mismatch and the
residual basically
um is going into the loss function and
these are just the the first term here
is just associated with boundary
conditions so maybe
um maybe we can forget that for the
moment
um so that's the idea of a pin and then
the reason that this all sort of works
out nicely is because
um one can one doesn't need any data
because one can obtain these derivatives
so in this case I need the second
derivatives with respect
um with respect to the independent
variable operating on u in order to
compute the laplacian right but the
thing is through uh back propagation I
can get I can just basically do auto
grad to get all of those derivatives for
free so this comes to the case where
um uh where I I don't actually need uh
some sort of data or anything I can
automatically compute what those
derivatives should be and I can just
take them into the loss function
so basically back propagating through
the neural network to compute what the
what the derivatives are
so in bad times you can approximate or
you can put a any sort of pde into this
thing
gotcha thank you
um my second question is I think uh you
showed one of the problem in not
achieving high accuracy in pin is the
the loss function so you have you
because we monitor this residual yeah
especially in this linear algebra sense
a u equals to F I think a lot of
traditional methods like gymras is also
a minimization problem based on residual
the based on the residual Norm
um doesn't seem is too much a problem
for krilloff method or other traditional
numerical method but it seems like the
conditioning is a really
a pain in this context do you have
comments on that
uh yes right so good point um yeah so uh
yeah so one can argue about whether or
not
um whether or not this problem of this
this sort of square condition number is
pervasive to all minimizers or whether
one can just somehow uh pick a better
minimizer and and be okay
um part of the thing here is that this
is and that's part of the limitations of
this linear algebra example is that is
is just a linear algebra example and if
one wanted to do this on the actual uh
sort of through the neural network then
then um something like cry Lobster's
based method would not be appropriate
um
and uh NGM res wouldn't suffer in the
same way
um so basically the only way as far as
I'm aware to get around this is to give
away the P equals two Norm to give or to
give away any p uh P even Norm
um and uh and to settle with like a P1
Norm but that has its own problems to
settle for an odd for an odd Norm
uh that that that would be a solution
but I think but it comes with other
problems that um I think would not be
conducive to to the type of things that
people usually care about
okay all right thank you thank you
okay thank you uh let's move on to John
Ragusa let's
we're giving you a chance to ask
questions John
hey thank you great talk I liked it a
lot very interested in pins
I also have lots of issues with paint so
maybe I'll send you an email later but
let me just ask a couple of questions if
there's time have you tried cases uh
where the PD has greatly varying
coefficients let's say for example as in
a you know heat conduction problem but
you have conductivities in different
materials and the conductivity is maybe
vary by Factor let's say a thousands of
really severely heterogeneous cases
um
can see the pins approach seems to
always find solutions that are overly
too diffusive and they don't have sharp
gradients uh be interested to know what
you think of of those more real life
situations worked with heterogeneous
problems
uh yeah if you have a problem that can't
uh that you can't normalize the scale so
you I guess you have these uh nasty sort
of rough coefficients that you're
talking about then
um so the the quick answer is no I
haven't tried it
um uh and and maybe I should
[Music]
um
uh
and whether or not I suspect that
something like what I presented is is
somehow a cure to that or not
um
I I don't I don't know I mean the like
your comments about the the fact that
your your PIN result gives on this type
of uh highly heterogeneous problem gives
a say overly diffusive solution or
something like this
um it's not I guess one would first have
to know what what to really attribute
that problem to
um which can be a challenge but I mean
it it's not clear to me immediately
whether that's due to maybe
um whether or not the pin has been
sufficiently trained
um and so the loss function is
sufficiently low because another thing
that is is is at least intellectually
interesting about pins is that they can
come up with solutions to pdes because
there's no data involved right so they
can come up with Solutions of pdes that
are also that are that are solutions
um but they just aren't the one that you
were thinking you would get uh so so so
people have actually used this to fine
to like show that maybe you can actually
get like non-unique solutions to things
like the nevastatic equations so
actually a recent uh some recent papers
on on the Millennium prize type problems
for NVA Stokes have uh have touched upon
that um so that's another possibility
um but unfortunately I I can't really
speak much more to uh to to the to the
type of uh problem you're talking about
no worries I think I'll send you an
email later today or maybe this weekend
I'll tell you a few things about what
I'm what I'm doing and what the issues
I'm having now I have another quick
question if you you allows me is it okay
okay very very quick what do you think
what do you think of training the new
generation of of graduate students on on
those tools should they also learn
traditional methods or is it or is it
going to be a thing of the past I'm just
curious what your opinion is on this
training them to do what to do these
kinds of neural network type things you
mean yeah yeah you know maybe there
would be a less an emphasis on learning
uh you know finite elements find a
different type of schemes of you know
what what we call traditional methods
what do you think would this takeover is
there room for both techniques who oh
well is there some some tension in
between the two what's your opinion
uh I think um people are trying these
things because they partially because
they're trendy and partially because
they've run out of other options but of
course yes young young folks coming into
grad school
um want to try the trendy things that's
uh that that has always been the case
and um and and and pins is definitely
not the first example of that
um and and sometimes these things prove
to uh stand sort of the test of time so
to speak and uh and and sometimes they
do not
um so I I guess I don't claim to have
any any more Clairvoyance than that
um but uh uh I do think that uh I mean
the only the only thing I think is that
uh anything that involves not uh
thinking about the the math Behind these
things in some sort of careful way is uh
very risky because you end up in this
situation where your results may not be
good and you have no way to reason about
um why they aren't good and so if you
don't understand the map then you're
you're really out of luck because the
neural network also is opaque so it
doesn't offer you
um it doesn't offer you some sort of
something some other information in
which you can
um sort of inform your priors and and
make a better choice about a model or a
differential equation or something like
that
yeah thank you so much
thank you all right thank you let's move
on to Henry
um Henny are you there oh hi hi I'm here
can you hear me yeah
oh sure hi uh yeah thank you thank you
for the talk uh I just wonder so you use
the PD residual as your loss function
that you want to minimize in your
problem so I was just wondering what are
your thoughts on like does it make sense
to use like a physics based functional
like for example like for the diffusion
equation you can Define the
thermal dissipation functional and then
you can just minimize that to get your
solution for diffusion equation like the
what are your thoughts on you're using
that as your loss function
uh right so a pin in this context at
least only purports to be able to only
purports to be solving a pde that is
prescribed and now what you're I think
alluding to is the idea of adding
additional terms that are associated
with the physics that may also be
relevant and so one can of course pile
on these sort of additional constraints
and terms in the in soft terms into the
loss function in the hopes of getting a
better result
um but then it's just a matter of what
do you consider a better result
um if what people have have been playing
around with this idea if I go back to
um here
um what what basically uh there there's
whole there's whole spaces here where
people are thinking about physics guided
loss functions right all the way down
here so all of these papers are thinking
about how do I add things to that are
relevant to the physics that are maybe
aside from just the pde and um if
there's one thing that I've learned it's
that these things are a bit
um hard to say uh
they I think they kind of missed the
point that if the neural network is is
behaving appropriately and in a way that
you expect then you don't need these
things
um and so and so in a sense they're kind
of uh stop Gap sort of solutions to get
something that looks kind of how you
want it to look
um but if but otherwise if it's if it's
not giving you the solution that you
expect that then maybe there's something
more interesting going on
um which is what we found and I think it
I think that that's actually why the
things that are shown in the slides here
um have gone sort of unnoticed for so
long because people were thinking about
these other types of things and not just
thinking about like what is like the
actual math going on in this thing
hmm
okay oh thanks thanks thank you okay
let's move to Walid are you there
yes thank you for the opportunity and
thank you for that great presentation
I'm really glad that someone is finally
addressing the Lost functions and the
optimization issues associated with pens
my question my first question is in
regards to the boundary conditions
you're using for the poissons equation
if you can describe them briefly
uh I believe that we just did um
periodic no uh I think uh no no sorry
just uh dear slay boundary conditions
um correctly on that problem
it would be interesting to see if you
can use some human boundary conditions
with sources on sinks because that could
be a very challenging problem
uh my second question is in regards to
mixing the other types of uh
losses and the loss functions so if you
had some data so you have a different
type of uh let's say a mean square error
with the min max loss function is that
something that's possible
uh yes it's certainly possible
um either a priority or rape historiore
I mean that's the other part of what was
actually inside of the uh the the paper
here
um so uh yes you certainly can add these
other data data constraints so if you
know that
um that uh the data is is is whatever it
is then you can add you can add it to
perhaps do better do better here in
terms of your training and get a better
result
um the only concern that I I I sometimes
have about mixing and matching these two
things is that the data comes with its
own
um uncertainties and whether or not the
data is behaving exactly as the pde that
you stick in this loss function is may
not be always clear
um so whether or not it's obeying the
exact uh you know incompressible in the
base Stokes or something to this effect
um is is that always obvious and if that
is the case then you could end up with
sort of tension between these two
different types of loss function that
may not give the results you expect
um and but that that's that's like a pin
thing not necessarily
um something specific to the type of
architecture that I was talking about
all right thank you very much thanks
great talk question
thank you
okay uh John
are you there
oh baby he's not there uh but he left
the chat in the chat um great talk can
you please share the paper and the code
in the in the chat yeah so uh well uh I
don't have access to the chat at the
moment but uh they're they're here and
if this is important then they'll be
they'll they'll be available they're
awesome they're also just on my website
so yeah all right sounds good uh feijo
are you there
oh um just a very um question so can
this idea of
um
[Music]
regression problems
can it be applied to what yeah
sorry say it again
regression oh General regression
problems
um yes
um yes it can it's just that I'm not
sure the benefits are are so obvious
um uh it depends on what kind of
regression problem you have but if uh I
mean if for if if the regression problem
is solving is is uh has the same types
of uh poor conditioning then one can
certainly reformulate this sort of loss
function this way
um
and so that yeah so there's there's many
applications of this type of uh
competitive uh tension that give that
that are useful
um and one can find them in the in the
papers that are referenced in our paper
uh of which there are many
um and uh you can uh and you can have a
look and and see there there really are
quite a few I just didn't have enough I
have time to talk about all of them
all right um thank you
um
are you there
uh he's not there all right uh so that's
the all I have from the chat but
is there anyone who wants to ask
questions or need yourself and do so
that's a quick question yeah go ahead
yeah this is Andrew Gillette I really
enjoyed your talk thank you uh I'm
curious there's some work that was like
gradient informed pin where they uh you
know do slightly better than pin results
by incorporating gradient information
um have you compared your work to that
and and if so how did it compare
uh no kidding uh we compared our work to
many different what I would call uh
training tricks
um where uh One ads basically one's
trying to accelerate training or somehow
ameliorate these costs that uh that are
uh that show up
um in order to to get better results and
so there's a whole sort of alphabet soup
of different pin methods
um and uh uh and so it's true that I
think these gradient things do give
better results
um there's there's I guess two things I
would note the the first is that uh none
of them seem to to my eye to actually
address what is the actual problem
um and so I mean if you can get a better
solution without addressing the actual
problem then I think I mean that's fine
but uh at the very least I wanted to to
note it uh to note that this is what
what is likely going on
um and uh and the other is that uh these
um many of these other sort of training
tricks that
um that that one of which you're
alluding to um but but there are others
um uh like um like uh
like mini batching and and all these
other things
um we've tried some of them because
reviewers wanted to see them
um but in principle they can all be just
added to our method anyway so uh in some
sense they're in different categories
makes sense thank you thank you sounds
good well um it's 7 after 11. uh Spencer
thank you so much both
staying with us for the extra time
um of course I'm glad I was able to get
to some of these questions ah wonderful
okay so I'm sure there are more
questions but let's wrap up here and
then um oh yeah say hi to someone
that's a good to meet you here yeah yes
hope you're having a good time at
Lawrence Livermore on your in your first
week
yeah it is his first week yeah I am
having a good time here yeah
very good awesome uh well thank you
Spencer again uh let's think um I'll
close one more time and uh yeah I mean I
hope
uh you will increase the collaboration
with the Lawrence Livermore National Lab
as well I mean as you do with other
other National Lab right or preacher and
the San Diego National Guard right
please consider us okay
yeah so it'll be my pleasure
all right sounds good okay let me push
the stop button for the recording